elizabeth is with us in canada hi
elizabeth how are you
hi i am thankful to god for his
blessings
amen me too
um so my husband's 29 i'm 34 we're
expecting our first baby in july
we don't have any debt except for our
30-year mortgage
we have about 280 000 left on that
we've only owned it for a little over a
year we have 30 000
in our emergency fund and we
have about 43 000 just sitting in our
savings that we've
saved up and kept there and we're kind
of a little bit
divided on what to do with that so my
husband
looks at the numbers and he wants to put
it in
investments for retirement and i hate
having the house debt and i know that
it's not a huge chunk in relation to
what we owe on the house
but i know that it would help pay down
the principle and i just i hate
owing on the house i don't like the debt
and we don't have any other debt so it's
like that's the one thing
um so but numbers why is he thinking it
won't get us ahead
as fast as investing will when you're
looking 30 years down the road
so i guess with the question is with
that forty three thousand dollar chunk
should we pay down the principal on her
mortgage or invest now or
split it somehow or just i could just
say screw it and get a
brand new toyota tacoma that would be
like
well that's possibility okay
i mean if you're on board there you go
the uh uh
i mean if you have a purchase that you
need to make other than a screw it
purchase but i mean
a legitimate question that you want to
make then that might be a play
but basically what we teach is what we
call the baby steps and it sounds like
you're aware of them baby step one is
and two is to be debt-free everything
but the house three is an emergency fund
you've done that beyond that you have
this 43 000
which we would apply to uh beginning
your baby steps four five and six
simultaneously four is putting 15
percent of your household income
into retirement are you doing that
um well okay so yes and no so not 15 but
so the coolest thing is actually at my
husband's job
he makes about 90 000 a year and i'm
going to be a stay-at-home mom so i was
working but i'm not so
let's just say we make about households
90 000. so
at the end of each year his um company
gives him 12 of his annual income above
what he made
and we use that solely for investing so
it's not
we haven't he just started there he's
only been there for a little over a year
so
we've only received one and that's just
a it's a lump sum bonus
yeah exactly and so i think it's
intended for investing and that's what
we use it for just goes
right so we've only been investing for a
very short time because
so what i would do is change your system
then you do not have a 90 000
income you have 102 000 income okay
counting bonuses yeah okay give or take
101
but somewhere right in there and so i
would be putting fifteen thousand
dollars
a year of your money
systematically monthly into
retirement savings okay and that that's
a budgeting change
for you that's not that really doesn't
address the 43 000 but i would start
that immediately
i would not do what you're doing because
you might not get the bonus one year
and you need to you need to be in the
habit of steadily
investing 15 of your income
and the um so that that that's the
direction i would go
now the um then the next step is do you
have children
one on the way in july then uh we might
use some of that 43 000 to set aside for
kids college baby step
five and anything that's left beyond
that
i would put it on the house and uh and i
am also doing math
and part of the math i'm doing is data
that says that the typical millionaire
that we studied
in the largest study of millionaires
ever done in north america
shows that the typical millionaire has
paid off home and substantial money in
retirement
and what i just laid out for you will
get you there
substantial money in retirement 15 15
000 a year going into
retirement and uh then beyond that
uh uh you know you're putting the
the money toward every dollar above that
towards
getting the home paid off and the
typical person listening to the show
doing our steps
pays off their home in seven to eight
years
the typical millionaire pays off their
home in about 10
years but people following this stuff
tend to be a little bit more intentional
a little bit more intense
and move in that direction so somewhere
in that 7-10 range
house is paid for but it won't be if you
keep screwing around and putting the 43
000 in investments because quote unquote
i did some math
um which by the way was wrong